Rauchende Meiler, beißende Luft.
Das Köhlern war früher ein Knochenjob –
und er ist es auch heute noch.
Ich bin heute mal
für die Drecksarbeit zuständig.
Ich bin nämlich unter die Köhler gegangen
und mache heute aus Holz Kohle.
Das sieht nicht nur genau so aus,
wie vor Hunderten von Jahren –
es wird auch noch genauso gemacht.
Und warum die letzten ihrer Zunft so
an ihrem aussterbenden Handwerk festhalten,
das finde ich heute mal tatkräftig heraus.
Wie man aus Holz Kohle macht,
ist eine der ältesten Handwerkstechniken
der Menschheit.
Ohne die Köhler und ihre Holzkohle
hätten die Menschen nie gelernt,
aus Erz Eisen herzustellen.
Wo es viel Erz gab,
gab es also auch viele Köhler –
wie hier im Harz,
ein Mittelgebirge mitten in Deutschland.
Ich besuche die Feldmers,
eine der letzten Köhlerfamilien.
Wir wollen halt die Tradition erhalten,
zeigen, wie das Leben im Harz
damals hier so stattgefunden hat.
Von der Holzkohle
bis zum Erzabbau
bis zum Schmied.
Es hat kein Material geschafft –
die ganz normale Flamme vom Holz,
vom Feuer schafft es nicht,
Eisen zu schmelzen,
man braucht noch mindestens
die doppelte Heizkraft,
und das schaffte nur die Holzkohle damals.
Und wenn du Lust hast,
kannst du das alles nachher mal mitmachen.
Na klar!
Köhlerhemd, Köhlertuch.
Fehlt nur noch der Köhlerhut,
und fertig ist der Köhler in mir.
Als erstes errichten wir den Kohlenmeiler.
Quasi ein Haufen Holz,
den wir aber sehr aufmerksam und nach
einer bestimmten Ordnung zusammenlegen.
Der so genannte Quandel-Schacht
in der Mitte funktioniert wie ein Kamin.
Pro Meiler stapelt sich Buchenholz
im Wert von knapp 1.500 Euro.
Das sieht doch schon mal
ganz gut aus, oder?
Und der ganze Haufen muss dann
auch noch abgedeckt werden, luftdicht.
Also da kommt erst mal …
Wir nehmen jetzt altes Heu,
das stopfen wir in die Lücken rein.
Da muss ja die Erde drauf halten.
Das darf nicht da reinrutschen.
Und dann wird der zugeschaufelt mit Erde.
Und dann liegt da ein großer Erdhaufen,
der Erdmeiler dann.
Ist der Meiler erst einmal angezündet,
muss ich die Glut durch gezielte Stiche
mit Sauerstoff versorgen.
Aber Vorsicht: Bei zu viel Luftzug
kann alles abbrennen.
Also muss ich wieder abdichten.
Zwei Wochen lang wird der Meiler
Tag und Nacht bearbeitet.
Oh, es ist wirklich anstrengend.
Vor allem der Rauch brennt unglaublich stark.
Muss ich mich erst mal dran gewöhnen.
Tut richtig, tut richtig weh.
Zeit, einen Blick zurückzuwerfen.
Das private Köhlermuseum
der Feldmers zeigt,
wie wichtig das Köhlern als Wirtschaftszweig
bis zum 19. Jahrhundert ist.
So, ohne Köhlerhandwerk
gäbe es gar kein Eisen,
es gäbe keinen Bergbau,
die Schmieden hätten gar kein Material,
um Werkzeuge herzustellen.
Also, es ist schon 'ne Riesenrolle in der
menschlichen Entwicklung schon allein,
Holzkohle zu haben.
Also die Köhler mussten
die Holzkohle herstellen,
nur allein, um Eisen zu produzieren
und zu bearbeiten.
Kein Wunder, dass mit dieser Zunft
auch ein paar zünftige Rituale und Bräuche
in Verbindung gebracht werden.
Gut, Brand, Gut, Brand,
Gut, Brand! Und weg damit!
Das Köhlern war wichtig,
der Köhler blieb aber immer
ein zwielichtiger Geselle.
Lecker, oh, der brennt aber wirklich!
Der Köhler war der eigentlich ‘n eigener
Schlag Mensch auch früher?
Also war das so ‘ne, also so ‘n …?
Ein einfacher Waldschrat.
Hast du ja schon selbst mitgekriegt,
was der eigentlich
den ganzen Tag gemacht hat.
Dass der auch mitten im Wald lebte
bei den Meilerplätzen, bei den Kohlplätzen.
Also war der natürlich auch …
manche haben sich gar nicht
hingetraut zum Köhler.
So einer bin ich jetzt auch.
Ein kauziger Kerl aus dem Wald.
Und ernte meine eigene Kohle.
Die Harzköhlerei Stemberghaus
mitten im Harzer Wald
haben die Feldmers Anfang
der 1990er-Jahre übernommen.
Und mit ihr die Leidenschaft fürs Köhlern.
Das Holz hatten wir mal in der Hand.
Also wir haben es sogar als Stamm
noch hier auf ‘n Hof bekommen,
haben es aufgesägt, aufgespalten,
veredelt zu dem tollen Stück,
was wir jetzt hier in der Hand haben.
Und es ist sogar noch heiß,
also du könntest gleich damit grillen,
wenn du magst.
Ja und das lässt natürlich das Herz
jeden [jedes] Köhlers höher pochen.
Von den 50 Tonnen Holzkohle,
die hier jährlich noch hergestellt werden,
nehme ich zehn Kilo mit nach Hause.
Heute wird die Holzkohle
meist zum Grillen verwendet.
Ha! Meine erste selbstgeerntete Holzkohle.
Früher hätte ich ja nie gedacht,
wie anspruchsvoll das eigentlich ist,
Holzkohle herzustellen.
Aber es war super interessant,
in die Welt der Köhler mal einzutauchen –
auch wenn es für einen Tag genug ist.
Weil die nächste Herausforderung von mir ist:
sauber werden.